-Welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
Ladies and gentlemen...
happy Friday.
Happy Friday, everyone.
Let's get to some news here.
Well, guys,
the Department of Defense
just made a pretty
shocking announcement.
Watch this.
-The Pentagon now confirming
and investigating
this video of a UFO
captured by Navy ships
in California.
The big questions now,
what exactly is
that mysterious object,
and where did it come from?
-Anyway, have a great weekend,
everybody.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Wow.
Right now, there are only --
I mean, a UFO!
There are only two explanations
for a random flying object.
It is either aliens
or another gender reveal
that has gone way too far.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see the UFO again, Alex?
-Oh, my God.
-It looks like
a Totino's Pizza Roll
making its way
through our system.
I see it.
It's either a UFO or a Dorito
at the bottom of a pool.
[ Laughter ]
Nice to see the Navy
spent their military budget
on Nokia flip-phone cameras.
-Got it!
-Sure. It's a UFO.
Hey, this is exciting.
Today, President Biden had
his first in-person meeting
with a foreign leader,
hosting
the prime minister of Japan.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, when Biden started
telling him a story,
the 12-hour flight
suddenly didn't seem so long.
[ Laughter ]
"I used to go to Japan,
and we used to cook the sushi
on an engine block."
[ Laughter ]
What?
Yeah, a 12-hour flight to
discuss problems facing Japan.
Afterwards, the prime minister
was quoted as saying,
"This could have been a Zoom."
Some business news.
I read that Subway
has been struggling
and could be up for sale.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
For some reason,
peeling off sweaty cold cuts
like they're Post-it notes
and slapping them on sugar bread
isn't resonating
with customers anymore.
It's hard to say
if Subway's struggles
are from increased competition,
changing consumer patterns,
or maybe, I don't know,
their spokesman
being in prison for pedophilia.
It could be -- Any of those
could be the problem.
-Yeah, it's a pick 'em.
I don't know which one.
-I knew something was wrong
with Subway
when I dropped my sandwich
the other day
and it bounced back on my plate.
[ Laughter ]
They go to switch things up
over there.
Hey, if you're in the market
for a new car --
Anyone looking for a new car?
[ Cheers ]
Mercedes just unveiled
a $100,000 electric sedan,
and it does more than just
get from you A to B.
Watch this.
-The new electric car
from Mercedes
has all kinds of high-tech
features, including a nap mode.
The seat automatically reclines
to a resting level.
The interior lighting
and temperature
adjust to soothing levels.
The stereo provides
relaxing sounds,
and a starry night
appears on the dashboard.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's the feature
I've been missing.
"I'll be right back, honey.
I'm just gonna go out for
a 70-mile-per-hour nap.
[ Laughter ]
Not to be outdone,
the new Hyundais
have a little holder thing
for a pen.
-Ooh.
Class.
-Speaking of luxury,
I saw that two unlikely brands
have teamed up
to create some high-end
camping gear.
Check this out.
-Italian luxury label Gucci
is teaming up
with outdoor recreation company
The North Face
to take glamping
to a whole new level.
This tent is part of
the North Face Gucci collection.
The Gucci North Face tent
will cost you close to $3,500.
-Hmm.
-Yep.
The Gucci camping tent
goes perfectly
with your napping Mercedes.
[ Laughter ]
-I was already thinking that.
-You were?
-Yeah.
-You should check it out.
This is nice -- The tent also
comes with dry $20 bills
that you can use as kindling.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
"Throw another hundy
in the fire, hon.
I'm gonna go back
in the mansion."
The Gucci tent is kind of weird.
It's like being asked on the red
carpet, "Who are you wearing?"
You're like,
"Dick's Sporting Goods."
[ Light laughter ]
What do you think of that?
-Check, please.
-Some more business news.
Miller Lite -- Miller Lite
is selling one-sleeve t-shirts
for people to wear
when they get the vaccine.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, a one-sleeve
Miller Lite t-shirt
or as Walmart calls it,
"business casual."
[ Laughter ]
If you can't figure out
how to roll up a sleeve,
I think you've already
had your Miller Time.
It will be funny when you go
get the shot,
and it's in the other arm.
"The whole point of the shirt
is to --
I'll just wear it backwards."
Well, the fallout continues
in the wake of
the Suez Canal blockage.
There's now a shortage
of garden gnomes.
-Ugh.
[ Light laughter ]
-Today, everyone working
at Travelocity
looked at their gnome
like he was a bitcoin.
"We're rich!"
This is interesting.
In Siberia, a group
of volunteers
cleaned up trash around the city
on the anniversary
of the first human space flight.
And they did it in style.
Watch this.
[ Laughter ]
Is it me, or are the Disney+
spinoffs losing quality?
You get that?
If you're feeling like
you're having a bad day,
just remember,
there's a guy in Siberia
picking up trash in
a homemade Chewbacca costume.
And finally, a singer
in British Columbia
just set the world record
for the lowest note
ever recorded by a woman.
Listen to this.
-[ Deep voice ] ♪ La, la ♪
♪ La, la ♪
♪ La, la, laaaaaa ♪
[ Laughter ]
-I think one more note,
and her lunch would have made
an appearance.
That's actually bear for,
"Wow, is that tent Gucci?"
Did you hear about this?
White Claw is coming out
with a new drink
called "White Claw Surge."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah,
I've heard about that.
-It comes in a bigger
can than regular White Claw,
and it has almost
double the alcohol.
[ Cheers ]
It's gonna be a hit.
-Has twice as much alcohol.
-Yeah, it's gonna be
a big hit this summer.
-Huge hit. Big smash.
-People will be smashed, yes.
I thought it would be helpful
to break down
all of the differences
between regular White Claw
and White Claw Surge.
-Oh good.
-Help people out.
First, White Claw...
-Mm-hmm.
-White Claw Surge...
-Whoa. Okay, got it.
-Also, White Claw...
-Mm-hmm.
-White Claw Surge...
-Oh, that's good.
[ Laughter ]
You choose.
-Next, White Claw...
White Claw Surge...
"I'm just gonna do it
real quick!"
-[ Laughs ]
-"The panda's
getting close to me. Uh-oh."
-"He's mad."
-"He's mad.
He doesn't like me being here."
-"And that's all I remember."
-[ Scoffs ] What are you doing?
Here's another one.
White Claw's slogan is...
White Claw Surge's slogan is...
[ Applause ]
That's bad.
Next, White Claw...
White Claw Surge...
-You never know.
Next up, White Claw...
White Claw Surge...
[ Applause ]
And finally, White Claw...
White Claw Surge...
There you go. Now you know.
-Now I know!